Buenos días,
soy Steve de LingQ.
Hay gente que siempre me
pide que haga un video en español,
porque hace mucho
tiempo que no lo hago.
Voy a explicar un poco mi
proyecto, lo que estoy haciendo ahora.
Un desafío.
Debería buscar como se dice.
¿desfio o desafío?
No me acuerdo.
Pero esto es típico,
de lo que ocurre en el
aprendizaje de idiomas.
Porque hace mucho tiempo
que yo no hablo español.
Y no escucho tampoco el español.
Entonces es probable
que me confunda, que tenga errores.
Pero esto no es lo importante.
Porque no hablo español
tan bien como
el francés, el japonés,
o el mandarín.
Pero lo hablo a un
nivel determinado,
lo que hace que
si no hablo el español,
pierda palabras,
tenga errores,
confunda las construcciones.
Voy a buscar construcciones
de idiomas eslavos.
Porque mi cerebro esta
acostumbrado a pensar de esa forma,
como por ejemplo en ruso, en polaco.
Y al hablar en español,
al principio,
voy a buscar esas
soluciones para expresarme.
Pero al cabo de un rato,
volveré a hablar español como antes.
Y quizás aún mejor.
Porque siempre tengo
la impresión de que,
cuando dejo un idioma de lado
y estudio otros idiomas,
al volver al primer idioma,
después de un tiempo...
al principio es más difícil,
pero después de un rato
lo hablo mejor que nunca.
Bueno, el desafío que
estoy haciendo ahora
es de concentrarme en
el estudio del coreano.
Que es un idioma que he
tratado de aprender 2 o 3 veces.
Y cada vez logro alcanzar cierto nivel.
Pero no un nivel suficiente
para verdaderamente entender,
por ejemplo, podcasts
sobre política, económicas,
sobre filosofía, literatura.
Cosas que para mi
son muy interesantes.
Entonces esta vez,
durante 3 meses
voy a concentrarme y
voy a escuchar y leer.
Y hacer LingQs en LingQ.
Y revisar mis LingQs.
Y eventualmente voy a hablar.
Pero para mí, hablar
no es tan importante.
Porque puede parecer sorprendente
pero si yo escucho mucho y leo mucho,
mi capacidad de hablar
va a progresar.
Para los que veían
mi video con Hannah en coreano,
he tenido un salto hacia adelante.
Solamente a través de
la escucha y la lectura.
Claro que para hablar
bien hay que hablar mucho.
Yo siempre lo digo.
Pero para alcanzar un
nivel potencial en el idioma,
necesitas palabras.
Y las palabras se adquieren a
través de la lectura y la escucha.
Y yo estoy convencido
que después de 3 meses,
de estudiar concentrado el
coreano, yo no puedo decir...
Porque ese es otro tema...
Podemos medir en
LingQ, mi nivel de actividad.
Y si leo mucho, escucho
mucho, voy a obtener progreso.
Pero yo no puedo decir que
voy a hablar a un nivel de fluidez,
porque esto depende
de muchas cosas.
Pero si ustedes quieren
concentrarse en un idioma,
en el estudio de un cierto idioma
durante 3 meses,
van a progresar. Esto es cierto, ¿okey?
Para mí, que decidí
concentrarme en el coreano,
era muy importante buscar
contenidos interesantes.
Y he encontrado un sitio
de podcasts en coreano,
con transcripciones, con los textos.
Y es muy interesante.
Acerca de la política
en la república coreana.
Yo estoy muy contento,
solamente me falta el tiempo
para dedicarme totalmente a este.
Claro que el español
lo hablo no tan bien,
pero esto no es lo importante.
Si yo tuviera la posibilidad o
la necesidad de hablar más,
lo terminaré haciendo mejor.
Eso es todo.
Esta es una breve
discusión en español,
sobre lo que estoy haciendo
ahora con mi desafío en coreano.
¡Adios y hasta luego!